et maxime dénommée qu'avouer une
ancienne candidate de secret story
bâle a triché et connaissez les secrets
avant non on lui a filé avant ouais
quand elle a pu sortir de la maison
exceptionnellement pour une raison
médicale
3 2 1 pomper pomper alors au pardon des
personnes en fait n'avait pas visé la
tête
non mais non mais laissez tomber saiss
et why soir là en tout cas un beau j'ai
épousé ma mairie ni jongler entre les
deux
regardez ces maeva qui raconte maeva de
sa star a que deux secretstory qui
raconte comment elle a triché
on demande à benjamin castaldi tient
lundi comment ça s'est passé
également ça va vous je suis
complètement reste la piscine allait
ouvrir jusqu'à quel âge à l'hôpital de
sainte anne à paris avec quelqu'un de la
production pour me surveiller et donc
car médecin m'a pris mais quand le
médecin me prend si tu veux la personne
la production n'a pas le droit d'entrer
avec moi c'est personnel etc
du coup je me retrouve seul dans une
salle et la même bêtise bon donc tu
connais pas les sucres et où tu veux pas
savoir je dis non elle me vient je m'en
bats les couilles je fais dit tout est
là ma sortie tout est secret je savais
tout j'étais chaud qui voit là est ma
fille peut tricher c'est une infirmière
qui me dit tout mais bon c'est sa fausse
et le social est éliminé la sixième
semaine surtout mis d'accord donc donc
on s'emballe est le consomme à l'accueil
merci en tout cas bravo les deux ans à
produire une émission avec les deux pour
couler la chaîne ad prochaine